Wow. Such a baller, man.
Oh, Hey there.
I didn't see you there. Just working out, you know, as you know,
I'm turning into a fitness channel,
but now that you're here might as well give you a tour of my apartment.
So this is my personal gym, as you can see, it's pretty dope. Yeah.
This is where I get my guns. Get my pump on, but yeah,
let me show you some watershed. All right.
So here is the common area. Oh, actually, wait,
I want to show you this. Can you pass me my keys?
Yeah, this is wait. How's it work.
I should have rehearsed this before I got it.
Nevermind. All right. So here's the common area. And if you remember,
this is where I shot the scene with Baria where he did.
So yeah. So you still working for Microsoft,
he's still working for Microsoft. I don't know if you remember that, but yeah.
Welcome to my crib. These are all the boats. I'm pretty rich.
You know, that AdSense money gave me a lot of money. Situated on a Marina.
The Italian architecture of this waterfront community is striking
community amenities includes a Marina, boardwalk,
a junior Olympic sized swimming pool and spa overlooking Marina.
We live in a three bedroom,
two bathroom apartment with 1,416 square feet costing
at around 5,000 a month.
Further over you have something called like one apartments.
Those ones are like pretty luxurious compared to this one.
This one's probably at the lower end, but you know me, I just, uh,
it's really hard to,
it's really hard to like pay the bills when you're just the IC three,
but it's okay. You know, poor life. All right. All right,
here we are.
This is my Villa and I live here with two other roommates,
but they're not here now. So let's start with the garage.
All right. Here's the, this is.
This is probably the part of my tour because it's pretty messy, but, uh, yeah,
these are my snowboarding gear. As you can see, this is my snowboard,
my bindings, my boots.
And then I also have a $10,000 piano here that we don't use.
It's actually on the electric piano, but it's made to be like an upright piano.
Yeah. Uh, it's my brother's, uh, he's a rich. I'm not, that's why he,
he has good stuff. All right. This is my roommates.
I think he's doing some fashion thing. I don't know.
All right. Here's the washer, washer,
dryer washer, dryer. And then, yeah.
And then all the crap that we don't know where to put. We just put it here.
Not bad. All right. Let's go check out the living room.
Oh my God. UK water bottles.
All right. Okay. Oh. I have to.
Alright, so welcome to the hallway.
Not our sets of stairs. [inaudible]
all right. Right. When you come in,
you could see all my hand water bottles. Yeah.
I still haven't finished them yet. All right. And now we're in the living room.
Usually it doesn't look like this, but we're filming today. But yeah,
this is my Bitmoji. If you guys recognize it, it's usually on my interviews.
It's pretty dope. Yeah. So we got this love seat couch.
Uh, and then we also have the one that is more,
less comfortable, but more solid couch.
And then if, if you notice this is the fireplace, we can turn it on.
This is where we shot star three, by the way. So
yeah, pretty dope. And then if you go on to the kitchen area,
you could see,
you could see a beautiful clean table. And then you also have the chess board.
I mean, this is where we, uh, this is where we shot star three also. Yeah,
you got some barstools, but it's supposed to be here,
but I guess we then put it here, put this back.
All right. So to the kitchen, it's extremely dirty. Why? Because,
because I'm never in the kitchen, these, so I don't even use it. So I don't,
I don't even know where anything is, but Ooh, lots of protein shake cups.
I don't use it anymore, but I might start using them plates,
stuff like that. Let's look at the fridge. See what I got block. Yeah.
So none of this is mine, but yeah. It's okay.
All right. Let's go to my room now.
I shaved before that bathroom. Yeah. Don't film too much here.
It's disgusting. So let's go up.
Sorry.
Obviously I spend most of my time, my room.
So this is probably the best part of the tour. See already.
It's so fricking dope. I mean, come on, man. What else can you put as a,
as a poster down? Oh, it's so hot in here. Ooh.
Okay. Let me just turn on the heater. I usually have the heater on.
I like it at 80 degrees. Capops playing.
I'm going to stop that. I don't want to get copyright shredded.
But yeah. Getting a water. Let me take a break.
Okay.
All right. Let's go.
So here you can see is where I do most of my videos because I have a
light set up. So this is usually the main light. And then this is like,
kind of like a fill light. And then I have a tripod here.
I put my camera on and then I started on, I say, what's poppin.
You know? And then if I go alive, I usually have this thing.
This is one of my best investment because we can do is,
you can just put it here at a phone here. And then I just go live like this.
So easy. Yeah. This is my personal laptop.
I don't use it anymore aside for watching porn. But you know,
nowadays I do everything here. I edit my videos.
I watch movies, you know, I work and all of that.
And then this is my hard drive, my hard drive to keep all the files.
And then this is, um, the SD card slot.
So basically this is like my workplace.
And then also melatonin in case, you know, I can't fall asleep.
So I would use this. Uh,
this is the microphone that I use whenever I make those sit down videos.
These are all my lenses. I got kit lens. I got another kit lens.
I actually have two of these cameras because I love them so much.
They're to 87 S I'll put them all into the description below.
If you want to buy them, they're pretty good.
And then also these anal beads that keep my camera steady.
Yeah. And then here I have all my chargers, bury ports, you know,
I charged my phone and stuff like that. It's pretty dope.
So this is the bed. All the magic happens. And by magic,
I mean magic alone, because I can never get a girl here. You know,
you guys talked about this many times and yes, that is true, but,
but I have a backup plan. And let me show you.
Yeah.
I have a Japanese mattress that can
roll over right here. There you go. Boom. Yeah,
if ever I bring girls over, I can't,
I can't put her here because there's a 200 pound limit,
but the floor doesn't have a 200 pound limit. So there you go.
That's another bed.
Okay. Let's put this back. All right.
I'm gonna leave it here for now. Oh. God,
this room is small.
All right. Okay. What else? Oh, okay. So here you can see got my accessory.
I usually have a plate and a fork here,
cause I don't want to be liable for anything in the kitchen because I only use
one fork and one place. So they can't blame me for anything. I got my, uh,
I got my awesome painting. It's pretty dope. I got lube.
It's mostly for myself. I got, Ooh, look at this.
This is a dope comic book. I haven't read it yet. Kind of dyslexic.
I don't want to read, but yeah, let's see. Oh, I phone. Oh, it does not.
iPhone has a pixel, but yeah. And then in here I have utter crap.
I just store everything. Oh, all the wires because you know,
camera gears and all that. I have way too many wires,
converters stuff like this. Boom.
What else? Oh, I got a lot of banana holders.
Yeah. I got a lot of banana holders.
I never used them yet because I usually just eat the banana before I,
even before I even like before I even carry it. So I don't need that.
Okay. Out.
Holy. Okay. I think that's about it. You know,
I got art.
And then this is, this is my clean pile. This is my dirty pile.
That's usually what it is. Oh, I guess I'll show you my toys.
So far.
All right. So here's my corgi.
Very popular corgi, but one other toy. I don't know that I have,
because you know, I expose it last is called Bemo.
It's basically like a robot bus. Yeah. It's pretty cute.
He used to be my favorite until I got the corgi.
Hello? Okay. All right. Let's go back down.
All right. So that's, that's basically it.
So thank you for touring with me and, uh, uh, hope.
I hope you liked it. Uh,
in case you want to know this costs about $5,000 a month.
I paid 1,500 cause I got the smallest room and uh, yeah.
Oh yeah.
Don't forget to like and subscribe, you know, and do that thing.
Piece.